[Musique]
nous errons sont en plein tournoi dans
le japon féodal 250
s'ils gagnent ils pourront récupérer la
3e reliques du docteur simon ce qui leur
permettra enfin de le retrouver
malheureusement le pirate la buse et
elliot le robot ont été éliminées et
tout le poids de la mission se retrouve
sur les épaules frêles de thomas parce
que oui
thomas est toujours dans l'aventuré ces
foules
et c'est moi qui dois me battre contre
ça moi je l'aurais bien fait à ta place
1 mais le règlement interdit les femmes
de participer
moi j'ai toujours été pour l'égalité
hommes-femmes surtout si ça peut éviter
de manger ma faute et des amis j'ai
perdu un combat et ça m'était jamais
arrivé pendant toute ma vie j'ai gagné
17 ans 2 victoires à 17 ans tu ne sais
pas du tout c'est parce que j'ai encore
un oeil valide
ça me rajeunit pas de toute façon on
pouvait pas prévoir tout ça je sais pas
de votre faute si chaque caisse qu'il
rival au delà ça va les lionnes ce nom
pourquoi ils disent ni bague ou quoi je
crois que notre sphère de métal et on va
pleurer sans arriver aussi une fois à ma
naissance mais je ne veux pas pleurer
c'est une machine à café techniquement
je ne peux pas pleurer mais je suis
quand même triste
iris 9 supplémentaires et petit fils de
quoi de plus avoir de tout y est en
stock
c'est drôle non c'est dur iris je suis
triste parce que c'est de ma faute si on
ne retrouvera jamais le docteur simon et
que thomas va mourir moi mais ça ça va
j'arrive à gérer a donc on peut jouer vu
mourir quand je suis arrivée dans votre
famille iris j'ai tout de suite compris
où était ma place dans la cuisine entre
gérard et muriel qui sont le frigo et de
la vaisselle il faut s'intéresser au
petit personnel
mais si on revenait sur le fait que je
vais mourir moi ce matin le professeur
simon a toujours été gentille avec moi
il est le père que j'ai toujours voulu
avoir
alors que toi iris sa vraie fille tu ne
voulait pas de lui
c'est triste d'en haut aussi puisque ma
mort imminente quand il a disparu et
qu'il m'a appelé je me suis dit ça y est
c'est mon heure de gloire
je vais le retrouver et il me dira merci
fiston observé je pleure
le retard tepa votée je suis désolé il
ya dessus personae désolé de savoir que
je vais mourir par contre écoutez moi
personne ne va mourir et on va gagner ce
tournoi hockey et puis on va récupérer
la dernière reliques et retrouver mon
père et ça c'est grâce à toi ignoble
parce que t'es pas qu'un robot
maintenant terrain les habits voilà hdmi
merci faire du mode tristesse début des
modes reprise de confiance en soi
je suis content d'apprendre que je veux
pas mourir et j'ai hâte de savoir
comment c'est possible du coup thomas si
tu utilises pas force passe à ce
samouraï tu vas mourir
ok c'est pas du tout ce que je voulais
en temps la seule façon pour toi de
gagner le match c'est de pousser le
samouraï hors du ring
ok je sais faire ça moi aussi pour ça
qu'il faut que tu t'entraînes un genre
beaucoup de matches et dans cinq minutes
oh oui j'apprends vite puis j'ai fini
sniper elite 400 les tutos mais quand
même on peut voyager dans le temps je
vous rappelle on peut passer des heures
à s'entraîner ou en veut et quand on
veut
ok donc la question c'est au et quant à
prendre a poussé quelqu'un de très fort
quelqu'un de dos ça m'arrangerait tiens
qui mérite qu'on tousse des centaines de
fois sans ressentir de culte
bon tu as vu comment j'ai fait ou mal à
toi maintenant et on recommence vas-y
thomas hocquet jb oui j'ai ri pays les
pas tomber ou ça fait essayer de me
concerne ça n'est pas très chaud tout ça
ni le dommage je le fais des caisses
quelles sensations
ouais c'est cool hein de pousser hitler
d'un balcon ces kits c'est abbaoui c'est
vrai tu peux pas le prénom
la première fois que je vis ce petit
bonhomme c'est comme ça sans savoir
quand je vois quelqu'un près d'une
fenêtre je le pousse c'est dans ma
nature
on va éviter de s'approcher trop près du
bord alors elliott or par en arrière
thomas soit m sur les applis retourne
il y avait vu un petit choc est plus
rapide
1 2 3 bientôt les notes
demain au caire et bmc bizarre j'ai bien
peur que nous voulons c'est impossible
chaque fois qu'on remonte dans le temps
la réalité redémarrage on y retourne une
poussière samouraï j'ai l'impression
qu'il sait qu'on repousse à chaque fois
c'est vraiment bizarre on recommence
thomas tu dois être prêt au cas où
alors les plus est anormal mittler a
disparu de la pièce où tu te caches
petit bonhomme avoue on n'a plus
personne à pousser fin de l'entraînement
et l'at on retourne à notre tournoi
ok je pense que je me sens prêt je peux
le pousser
ce parti pour la terreur takeshi le
grand saut droite et la fierté de
relations entre ankara
juste les adversaires se salue
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur gagne
[Musique]
il aurait dû pousser son adversaire non
pas seulement rebondir contre lui
contrairement à hitler le samouraï est
très lourd 90 kg de muscles plus une
armure
c'est plus dur du coup tu m'etonnes mais
samouraï a même pas bougé avec son
armure et me fait super mal aux mains
regardez c'est tout la charge thomas n'a
pas suffi mais maintenant c'est la
question qu'il sort lentement son katana
ça parle de thomas qui je me suis alors
[Applaudissements]
il semblerait que le mal sont reproduits
par terre et sur le côté est en position
foetale
il avance à main près de son visage ils
s'opposent et de mela ça bouge pour le
tt
qu'est ce que je vois là non merci
on était bien goûter celle-là nous ça va
avec cette histoire c'est trop triste et
terriblement gênante je propose qu'on ne
dise pas à sa mère comment il est mort
on dira qu'il est tombé d'une falaise en
jouant à pokémon bord c'est une à
radieux petit matelot chétif est en
berne
ce passe-t-il takeshi le bronze à doral
et figé sauf qu à tranas à la main il ne
donne pas le coup de grâce
attendez attendez je crois qu'il va dire
quelque chose
ce n'est pas un combattant
c'est un enfant j'ai déshonoré mon clan
home battant contre lui je ne mérite pas
de vivre
oulala takeshi retourne là là contre lui
[Musique]
cacher ses comptes
défaite par hara kiri
comme on en a
aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas mais tout fait
c'est vrai que dans notre pays on ne se
suicide pas avec le dos les pierres ne
te rapporte la relique ancestrale
qu'elle était par la danse très grande
incidence que la télé m'en foutais ainsi
qu'un magnifique bar tu t en bronze sont
steve les gagnants se suicider pour
laver son honneur d'avoir gagné d'une
manière aussi ont tous gagné on n'a pas
eu le temps
j'ai quoi compliquer un avantage à
béthune a fallu utiliser la pression
psychologique
je suis pas seulement un physique vous
savez je suis aussi un fin stratège donc
c'était une ruse évidemment c'était pour
de faux mais ça sent le vrai pipi d'un
ton pantalon à pattes désolé je voulais
que ce soit crédible alors oui j'ai
utilisé mon urine pour père
transparaître la peur ça s'appelle
l'acting madame le plus important est
qu'ils aient gagné allons retrouver le
shogun pour récupérer la relique
étrangers vous savez gagner le grand
tournoi avec quoi je ne peux pas dire ça
vous avez gagné quoi la relie à oui
c'est plus la relique ancestrale confie
sarah prenez ce truc est cassé votre nom
pareil à échanger votre pantalon la
drache 500 jusqu'ici merci m et mai la
relique c'est une bague de petite taille
mais d'une incroyable finesse
oui c'est le photos de la cuisine je le
reconnais le docteur simon l'utilisait
pour couper les légumes
il s'appelle comment ce couteau raymond
fabris c'est un couteau thomas
les objets n'ont pas de prénom non mais
c'est pas que ça c'est le bouton que je
lui ai offert pour la fête des pères
quand j'avais 10 ans à 10 ans j'étais
encore avec ma première femme
non mais la première reliques c'était un
cadeau de mon père la deuxième aussi et
celle là c'est un cadeau que j'ai fait à
mon père c'est par hasard tu es sûr
c'est pas juste des objets qu'il a pris
au hasard chez lui mais non ça veut dire
qu'il essaie de me faire passer un
message
ça veut dire qu'ils pensent à moi et qui
compte sur moi pour le retrouver
oui enfin je te rappelle qu'il
m'appelait moi à la base comme un père
qui demande de l'aide à son fils oui
était venu me retrouver après il savait
que j'allais faire ça et que j'allais
retrouver ces reliques
il savait pour moi aussi ah non non non
ils savaient pas pour toi tu es un
accident de parcours toi si ça fait
toujours qu'ils jugent toujours dans mon
problème
ah oui pardon il y a qu'est ce qu'on
fait je fusionne les coordonnées des
reliques
[Musique]
si bon j'ai décoder de nouvelles
coordonnées temporel au cas où cette
époque et ce lieu ne vont pas vous faire
re temporal isation immédiat
la lame et où nos héros vont ils encore
atterrir et que va-t-il leur arrivée
pour le savoir il va falloir acheter le
dernier épisode pour la modique somme de
99 euros
il sera gratuit comme les autres c'est
une bonne nouvelle
rendez vous pour la fin de l'épopée
temporel
c'est pas
angers grand maman tu les appelles c
notre aventure touche à sa fin iris la
buse elliott no 3 et roues ainsi que
thomas ont enfin récupérer les trois
reliques et partent vers les cordes
n'est laissée par le docteur simon je
suis trop pressés que vous entendiez la
femme vous allez voir c'est ouf c'est
calme nous sommes dans la banlieue de
mela 1997 d'en faire acquérir 17 degrés
lui fit bas je pensais que le futur
ferait plus rêver malheureusement ce
sont les années 90 époque la plus
chiante de l'humanité c'est être ici en
fait l'infiniment au moyen d acné
auteurs n'y a rien tout ce chemin pour
ça pourquoi mon père nous a menés
justice il faut qu'on s'active
ça fait au moins deux heures qu'on dise
que ça fait vingt secondes en bon sens
ce lieu est maudit cette déchirure
aveuglante devant nous m'a tout l'air
d'une faille spatio temporelle allez
quoi y'a quelqu'un l'intérieur n'ont
qu'à regarder chanter pour rencontrer
cette honda center simon au son de la
faille
ils essaient de nous dire quelque chose
vous entend pas allez on y va
c'est parti la grèce va pas leur donjon
c'est vraiment tout blanc partout des
iris
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu toi kb 28
je suis heureux de vous retrouver
docteur simon vous m'avez appelé à la
rescousse et j'ai apporté votre fille
elle est comme une soeur pour moi vu que
vous êtes comme un père qui eux enchanté
monsieur ouais je me présente la ruse
je vous tu m'aimes pas parce que mes des
amis me l'ont demandé mais pourquoi la
phase 6 refermer été bon papa rod a
retrouvé et on a récupéré les molik
comme tu nous la demande pour un les
balises retour nous avait enlevé les
balises retour mais c'est pour ça qu'il
a failli se refermer
pourquoi vous savez fait ça mais c'est
toi qui les a placés pour qu'on les
récupère ce sont des objets qui nous
relient papa des cadeaux quand c'était
fait pour prouver qu on était une
famille mais pas du tout j'ai pris des
objets au pif à la maison des trucs qui
pouvait ressembler à diabolique pour que
personne ne touche jamais j'ai inséré
des balises pour assurer mon retour et
vous avez tout foutu en l'air on ne
pourra plus jamais sortir d'ici
tucat comprend quelque chose la
situation est délicate récesion on est
dans la merde pourquoi vous pensez que
je les ai caché à des endroits très
précis et que j'ai demandé aux gens sur
place de les protéger
sans elles la faille se referme je me
disais bien qu'il était bien gardé ses
balises à récupérer un moment j'ai même
fallu faire la remarque mais comme il y
avait des conquistadors qui essaient
nous tuer sam est sorti de la tête quand
je vois c'était une triangulation multi
temporel fixe pour maintenir la faillite
font plus que thomas astucieux kb 28 tu
ne pouvais pas le comprendre à vendre
quand ça vous arrange
je suis une cafetière mais tout d'un
coup je fais une erreur de jugement sur
un procédé qui relève de la mécanique
quantique et je vous déçoit super faire
semblant d'avoir tout compris raquette
je fais ça tout en attend les reliques
n'avait rien à voir avec moi je pensais
que mais pourquoi tu m'expliques jamais
rien tu m'a jamais parlé
t'as jamais le vélo n'est que des
machines de fonctionner du tout au
contraire
iris si j'ai fait toutes ces recherches
pour trouver cette faille c'est parce
que quand tu es né je me suis rendu
compte de la valeur que tu avais j'ai
voulu maîtriser le temps pour pouvoir en
passer plus souvent avec toi mais tu
aurais pas pu tout simplement passer du
temps avec moi dès le départ la logique
du docteur simon se tient mais je
préfère largement ses ministres de toute
façon on a tous notre temps maintenant
puisqu'on est bloquée ensemble ici dans
cet espace vide pour l'éternité
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça si on fait
comme quand les pirates découvre une
nouvelle ils ont rappelé cet endroit non
non je suis la seule femme j'ai le choix
entre un pirate un robot mon père et mon
ex
alors on va rien peuplée du tout dr
simon voilà c'est pour vous dire que
j'ai traversé toutes ces épreuves pour
vous dire que
[Musique]
la poussière fichtre kouassi toublanc
d'amyris
il est ouvert aux [ __ ] la hitler dans
une faille ton pour elle qui donne tu es
aliénor la reine du moyen âge c'est
précisément ce qui vient de se passer
c'est fou ces ponts qui m'a fait pousser
des centaines de fois par la fenêtre
je me souviens c'est par ici et ça c est
derrière moi
jusqu'à ce que je sois est spécial
c'était bouclé pas qu'il avait indiqué
que j'apparaisse qui s'y plier chier je
suis défait du fou je suis
est-ce que vous avez encore faible
disons qu'on s'est amusé à pousser et
l'air d'une fenêtre une faut sortir de
cette fois jusqu'à ce qu'ils
disparaissent du temps sinon il aurait
continuer encore longtemps le fanion et
marc furrer
et c'est ainsi un karaté cette fois
qu'on lui ce matin
les serbes
compétent mais bnp perd guerrier sans sa
moustache à cette couleur elle est
toujours sonné en bataille mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez foutu qu'on est
coincé dans une faille temporelle avec
indique claire démoniaque
c'est vrai petit comme ça on peu foutu
la mer jusqu'à maintenant j'ai été
plutôt j'ai dit à ma vie des là je vais
être là comment il peut être encore plus
méchant admirer ce qui va sortir de ma
bouche un adversaire
m'occuper de ces coups de feu avec ma
célèbre passe
arrête de renvoyer mais vous vous allez
être surpris mais je me suis un peu fait
pipi dessus je n'imaginais pas du tout
finir ma vie comme ça enfin point commun
syndical qu'une solution optimale
disponibles d'atr j'ai trouvé comment
les sortir de cette mauvaise passe
regardez mon plein oui j'avais oublié la
machine de la rédaction prendre de
machine à voyager dans le train il
confessa oui bien joué qu'à 28 prêtait
la meilleure machine à café
merci docteur attend il ya pour réaliser
ce plan il faut te démonter entièrement
inutilisés des pièces exactement les
machines aimé qu'opposant serviront à
construire un bon texte dans une fenêtre
ça peut fonctionner
elliott tu veux mourir je vais cesser
d'exister mais ce n'est pas grave j'ai
découvert l'amitié avec toi iris
je sais au fond de moi que je serai
toujours ton frère même si tu ne veux
pas être m'assurant et docteur chaque
café que je vous ai fait a compté pour
moi au niveau microscopique j'ai
toujours écrit papa je t'aime avec les
grains de sucre
c'était mon secret je crois que j'ai
découvert l'humanité auprès de vous tous
j'ai cru que c'était un bug mais c'était
de l'amour c'est la seule solution je
met un on se revoit de l'autre au
prêteur
[Musique]
je commence à fatiguer ce moustachu est
sacrément coriace face aux déguisements
y en a encore pour quelques minutes pour
construire le vantex appartient des
grecs ont atteint d'une toiture est
juste là sans bouger et va porter ça
c'est une mission combres rester
célibataire j'étire des lasers avec les
yeux mais c'est n'importe quoi et c'est
sur mon enfance au café de versailles
est une pierre d'une affaire avec ses
shows se trouve à bout c'est thomas
müller vient plutôt de bach par ici toi
tu va coûter 1 mais laser est sous le
coup de la mort monsieur dray prix qu'à
moi c'est bon tout ça en place
le vortex devrait souffrir ok ça peut le
faire tomates syrte après ma part
couvrant la tête
dommage souvent mais je n'ai plus peur
des fenêtres nous sommes coincés ici
tout se joue selon thomas comme on dit
dans ton pays regardent les deux
machines à voyager dans les fenêtres ont
créé un cortex hitler tombe à l'infini
fahouët comme d'importance
on l'a trouvé quelqu'un de plus cruel
que moi j'adore ton père et c'est cruel
mais mon ressort dit ça quand tu vas
voir c'est plus très long
alex tagliani exactement ces chutes et
son désarroi l'ont fait tomber ici et de
nouvelles chutes et son désarroi
on crée une nouvelle faille et tout le
monde sait qu'une faille dans une faille
c'est une sortie une sortie créé avec le
som d'hitler un jus ni aller on ça
elliott
tu vas nous manquer j'ai connu des
humains - humain qui avec son livre
aleris on rentre mais laisse-moi la
machine cinq minutes papa je vais
déposer demain
ok mais ne met pas trop de temps cette
époque le fout le cafard dirais que
c'est le moment de se quitter
au revoir à mon garçon parfois les
rencontres tu apprennes plein de choses
et avec toi rien du tout à part l'amitié
et je me suis beaucoup amusé ravi
d'avoir rencontré la buse ne change rien
sauf les viols et les assassinats
allez thomas misa docteur simon la buse
je vous dis au revoir
tu es revenir mais je vois que ta
ramener ta petite copine
comme quoi le physique c'est pas
important merci maman iris moi dans ma
chambre
allez voilà ma chance j'ai sauvé de
machault c'est quoi ces fouilles mais ce
truc je suis parti comme une tare deux
jours il y aura fait t'es pas voir ci
après j'ai rechargé une sauvegarde dans
une autre cafetière et je suis venu vous
rejoins mais on croyait que tu étais
mort pour toujours non je vous ai même
dit on se revoit de l'autre côté du
monde croyait que ça voulait dire on se
trouvait au paradis non vous bien que
mon nom c'était de l'autre côté de la
faille
c'est vrai que vous les humains vous
prenez beaucoup de risques pour des gens
qui n'ont pas de sauvegarde
en tout cas je suis très heureux de voir
que mon plan à marcher mais je crois que
vous avez des choses à vous dire merci
et bien bon thomas assieds-toi sur cette
balançoire en cuir s'applique maintenant
pas seul avec des pics en volailles je
sais qu'on a vécu des aventures folles
ça c'est clair et c'est vrai que ça nous
a rapprochés c'est bon je sais c'est
fini entre nous d'abord pour toi savais
pas vraiment comment ces chiens que ça
intéresse pas mais je te comprends c'est
ce que je voulais dire à ton père je
voulais dire que si j'avais la chance
d'avoir une personne comme toi dans ma
vie aucune machine aucune invention des
cartes raymond regarde elle si gentil
c'est bizarre je vous imaginer vivre
ensemble à avoir des enfants un chien
mais ça n'arrivera pas
iris thomas à un petit lapin qui parle
lui trop mignon territoire iris thomas
ce à propos de votre fils c'est urgent
j'ai besoin que vous suiviez à travers
le temps l'avenir de la planète on
dépend eu un enfant c'est parti et va
pas
et dans un instant la suite de l'
aventure de proches du club c'est la fin
de la saison
c'est ce qu'on appelle un cliffhanger
qui est ce lapin que s'est il passé
entre iris et thomas dans le futur
qu'est ce qui menace la planète
autant de questions auxquelles les
scénaristes mode aucune réponse
et ils sont pas dans la mer pour une
fois je ne sais pas tout j'ai hâte de
vous retrouver pour la suite de l'épopée
temporaire
à l'époque les
g
une grande aventure les appels
temporaire